what's your name uh Tim hey Tim Elise uh
my wife right here hey Elise how are you
really loved you Conan
um Matt love you guys oh I love you too
um I don't know them
but I know he's right we love you thank
you
um I was wondering will you guys be
doing any Comic-Con stuff in the future
well here's the deal we for many years
uh did Comic-Con every year through the
Late Night show and that was really fun
because no late night show had done
Comic-Con before there's an amazing
theater in downtown San Diego called the
Spreckels which is an old Vaudeville
theater that the Marx Brothers performed
in and I mean just this classic great
1920s venue and we would do shows that
were all Comic-Con themed and and they
were so much fun you were there for all
this there's probably some of my
favorite shows you've ever done there
are some of my favorite cold opens we
would shoot these incredible pieces
uh the bit parodied Mad Max and we would
use like film cameras and we would we
would uh really go to town and and we
did my origin stories
um and and the audience was packed with
people who had been a Comic-Con all day
so the audience was just filled with
Wonder Woman's and Hulks and Batmans and
I mean it was it was absolutely so much
fun to do it was and then the question
becomes now there's not a late night
show
um but there's a podcast but is there a
way that we could go back and I'd be
very intrigued because I loved going
there I love the energy of it it's one
of the greatest fan bases of all time
and I think it kind of neatly meshes
with our style of Comedy I think there's
like a nice symbiotic relationship where
we're fans of a lot of these films too
and uh it worked really nicely so I'd
love to say that yes in the future
there's no plan right now but in the
future I'd love to get back to Comic-Con
yeah and um you know I met my husband
after one of those shows after one of
the week of shows that's right tell me
what happened we were walking around we
had just finished a week of shows and we
were walking and me and a friend of mine
were walking around the actual Comic-Con
floor and then my friend knew the friend
that tack was walking with and then we
met hit it off and then right away did
you know yeah I did I did yeah but like
two years later we were married
yeah yeah I met my wife shooting a
segment for a late night with Conan
O'Brien and you threw the Conan show at
TBS yes so it is the greatest dating
site of all time if anyone's looking for
their their special person
um just come hang out with me and I
guarantee you'll meet them uh within uh
seven years
yeah that's really the best I can do
my lawyers have said you really can't
over promise